maintenant que les tarifs douaniers sur
l'acier l'aluminium sont levés et que
l'alena et re négocier ottawa et
washington passent en mode collaboration
constitue à parler des enjeux qui sont
importants pour notre pays
la priorité pour ottawa la libération
des canadiens michael covering et mac os
serveur détenu en chine depuis plus de
huit mois
mike pompeo est sans équivoque il
confirme que dans notre homme pas parler
de leur cas au président chinois lors de
leur rencontre cet été vous allez comme
le canada ils qualifient leur
arrestation arbitraire et d'inapropriée
il assure que les états unis
continueront de mettre de la pression
tant qu'ils ne reviendront pas à la
maison
la situation en comme préoccupe aussi
les deux pays
plus tôt dans la journée pékin accusé le
canada de tenir des commentaires
irresponsables et de se mêler de ce qui
ne le regarde pas christiane n'est pas
d'accord il ya trois cent mille
canadiens à fond quand et c'est naturel
est important pour le canada d'être dû
faire attention à ce qui se passe là si
le canada et les états unis semblent au
diapason sur la chine ils ne partagent
pas la même opinion au sujet de la
russie et de sa place au sein du g7
plus tôt cette semaine le président un
autre homme se disait encore favorable
un retour de la russie
mais ottawa n'a pas l'intention
d'accueillir moscou les bras ouverts
je pense que tout le monde sera très
heureuse d'un vettel a réussi dû être
membre encore une fois de j 7
une fois que la russie va partir de la
crimée va partir du dôme basse c'est
très simple les deux chefs de diplomatie
ont aussi réitéré leur demande pour la
tenue d'élections libres et
démocratiques au venezuela que chef
hélène se rendra d'ailleurs la semaine
prochaine
cuba afin de trouver une solution à
cette crise politique et s'est fait de
vincent choisi radio canada ottawa